The Joe Rogan experience and he works at,
so we run a math today,
so to run running and muck out really early,
early,
early run in the morning,
run at lunch.
Running at dawn is beautiful.
It's an African.
If you can mention the African dawn's I got coming up.
Were you worried about something running up and grabbing you well on that thing?
I wasn't,
I mean they,
they told me I supposed to have security.
I wasn't,
I was kind of cool that people,
we weren't about people.
You were around any,
I was la animals.
I was in a uh,
the mountain Zebra National Park and you know,
if you've ever been in the list of priorities they say,
so they tell you to sit in this shuttle shower bank,
big open top vehicle,
which got metal bars over it and they say the animals,
they know that the shape of that they knows metal and metal doesn't taste very
good.
So you'll be fine and there's a guy with a gun and you feel good.
But when I went there,
of course they said,
well,
you're running outside near the vehicle.
And I thought,
is this right?
This pretty be good television.
But
he said,
okay,
I'll just stay close to there's something's coming.
And they did.
I said,
what about how the lions during the lions have eaten yesterday?
They're fine.
And they told me,
you know,
and that's what lines they come.
They never go for snacks.
Lions are kind of organized like that.
We ate yesterday,
we ripped apart some animal and we don't need to go and have a bag of crystal.
They knew.
They knew that the line knew whether they knew where they were and that they
were okay,
but they said the buffalo are around and they can stamp you to death about.
I didn't their buffalo,
so black death,
they called them,
rarely call them,
blocked out the,
they're responsible for so much.
They're not as responsible as hippos.
Hippos are number one,
but they fuck a lot of people up,
man.
They don't take any shit.
Have you think about bowls like people when people try to ride bulls?
Yeah,
like domestic cow bulls.
They're ruthlessly aggressive animals.
Yeah.
I mean they'll fucking throw you through the air.
Now.
Think of them but wild and in Africa and fighting off lions and that's,
that's African buffaloes.
I mean they are for Roche's animals and that just,
I didn't know what I had to do.
I knew that with um,
hippos,
if you come in between their water source,
then they'll just kill you.
They'll fuck you up.
Um,
I didn't know what I have to do to buffalo's weather.
I had to write it.
Can't go anywhere near that,
into that Grand Mal.
Yeah.
If they find you to be a threat at all,
they're just so powerful.
They just launch you in there.
There's a great video that I was watching this morning of a lion.
It was trying to take out a small buffalo and the other one got behind the line
and launched it through the air.
It was literally flying like 40 feet in the air,
like flipping head over heels.
Cause this,
the strength of this thing to take a giant cat and just with its head,
she's woo and just flies.
That wasn't the one with the crocodile in it as well?
No,
no.
This was one that was on the side of a dirt road.
All right.
Have you heard about the curfew?
Busy go to busy wild on Instagram.
I think that's the,
uh,
have you heard about the Kroger gas?
I saw that,
yeah.
That's interesting,
isn't it?
Cause that I feel that buffalo,
there are acting like the local townspeople and that the,
I think the lines of the SS and the crocodile is another,
yeah.
This is it.
This is the video.
So it looks like the lions attacking this one.
Look at that.
Boom.
Oh,
it's actually not nearly as high as I thought it was.
Maybe I'm thinking of another one.
Yeah,
that one's pretty good though.
I mean,
just to see it do that.
Oh,
you know what I'm thinking of?
I'm thinking of relentless enemies.
That's what I'm thinking of.
There's a,
there's actually a,
um,
uh,
a documentary about this one particular strain of lion that there was a,
apparently the river split sides or the river changed its path and it turned
this area into an island and the lions had to adapt because the only thing that
they could eat was buffalo,
which is very difficult to kill.
You know,
they usually,
they're eating antelope and other smaller things that aren't nearly as
dangerous.
Right.
So these lions developed became far larger,
so the female lions are as large as a normal male lion and there hulking like
massive muscles and they're just enormous.
It's just enormous strain of lion that's exclusively eating buffalo.
And there's a whole documentary.
It's a national geographic documentary.
I think it's really good,
but it's just incredible to see these things walking around and they look
cartoonish to like the hulk.
Yeah.
So it's hard to tell.
You'd have to compare them to a regular line,
but there's some images of these things walking around.
They just look so much larger than a regular lion because they just had to
adapt.
Yeah.
And I would think that if you're running around,
like if you're running,
you've got to think like you're,
you look like something that's trying to get away.
What made running in that park?
Yeah,
no,
I was right next to the green vehicles.
So the big metal green vertical was there and they just said stay close.
So I was one door flip away from,
I just launched myself into the is open top.
So I would've been in that vehicle before they go out to me,
I hope.
Did you hear about the woman from,
she was an editor on the game of Thrones and she was in one of those parks and
she had a window rolled down and she,
they told her keep your windows rolled up at all times and she was trying to
take better photographs and the cat reached in and grabbed her and pulled her
out of the vehicle and killed her.
This is the last year or they're,
they're,
they're a dangerous creature.
Yeah.
And you're just out there running with them.
Well I they,
um,
yeah,
this is,
oh,
is that a picture of it?
Yeah.
Oh God,
they have a picture of it happening is in 2015.
Oh,
wasn't really that long ago.
That just looked it up yet recently knows my facts.
Terrible was flying,
bro.
Look at that though.
That is just so awful that they actually caught it on camera.
Well,
she just thought it was,
you know,
she was safe.
She was in the car.
I reached in and grabbed her and pulled her out.
Yeah.
I,
uh,
you're out there running around.
[inaudible].